-Good evening.
I'm Seth Meyers,
and this is "Late Night."
We hope you're all
doing well tonight.
As for us,
things have taken a turn.
Let's get to the news.
President Biden
is set to deliver
his first State of the Union
address on March 1st,
and it's the first one where
"union" is the only good news.
Republican senator
Lindsey Graham yesterday
criticized
President Biden's speech
commemorating
the January 6th Capitol attack,
and said Biden had
"politicized the event."
How do you politicize an event
that's already political?
They stormed the Capitol,
not a Best Buy on Black Friday.
That's like saying,
"Is it just me,
or is the priest's sermon today
all about religion?
We get it. We get it."
In a speech last week
commemorating
the one-year anniversary
of the Capitol attack,
President Biden criticized
the rioters and said,
"You can't love your country
only when you win."
Well, I guess some people
are just never meant
to fall in love.
Advisors to
former President Trump
reportedly believe that
a recent improvement
in Trump's favorability rating
is due to his diminished
social media presence,
and at this point,
Biden will try anything.
Scientists are currently
disputing a new study
that claims to have discovered
a so-called
"deltachron" strain
of the coronavirus
that combines
the delta and omicron variants,
and the only thing that can
stop it is the Pfizerna vaccine.
Scientists in England
recently announced
that they've named
a type of tree
after actor Leonardo DiCaprio,
and it's currently dating
a sapling.
A little tree humor,
for everybody out there
who's into that kind of thing.
New York Mayor Eric Adams
is facing criticism
over his recent decision
to appoint his brother
to serve as
the deputy police commissioner.
Said Adams,
"Cool. Take it up with my son."
I'm gonna say it right now --
I think this Mayor Adams thing
is off to a great start --
insofar as, you know,
monologue jokes.
Hot start.
Don't want to jinx it.
Mercedes-Benz recently unveiled
its new
all-electric concept car,
which is made from
several sustainable materials,
can travel 620 miles
on a single charge,
and takes up two parking spots.
BlackBerry last week officially
stopped supporting
its line of
signature mobile devices.
Of course,
I was totally prepared,
because I set a reminder
on my PalmPilot.
And finally, Taco Bell
announced its so-called
"Taco Lover's Pass"
subscription service last week,
which costs $10 a month
to receive one taco per day
for 30 consecutive days.
On the downside,
"Taco Lovers Pass"
will also be the headline
of their obituary.
Now that's the kind of joke
you can do, you know,
when you're
in an empty apartment.
You don't have to worry
about the groans.
Right?
Tell the jokes you want to tell
about Taco Bell.
What do you mean,
who am I taking to?
Who are you talking to?